[Music]
for
you have your
[Music]
now
for
[Music]
right
I
[Music]
Christian
for
[Music]
pleasure here
especially for a five o'clock service to
Rally yourself mobilize yourself and
whoever else you're bringing with you um
to to come to church so I just want to
acknowledge that along with the fact
that sometimes it can be daunting to
walk into a church just full stop right
there so good job um it takes courage
and uh uh I hope that wherever you fall
whether you are excited to to be here
tonight uh or a little reluctant or even
a little nervous um I hope you feel
warmly welcomed and at home here among
us at the table my name is Karen Miner
and I'm part of the leadership team here
hi
Shiloh and a uh warm welcome also to
those of you who are joining online and
I want to give a special welcome online
to my aunt Kathleen
who is joining us from out of state so
you can join the table from wherever you
are uh I just have two announcements uh
things coming up here at the table ways
to get involved the first one is we have
a youth Sunday coming up uh in two weeks
so on Sunday October
22nd yeah our table teens and their
leadership group they're going to take
over the service they're going to do
worship they're going to do
announcements they're going to do
communion in the last time they did it
it was like one of my all-time favorite
services and it's going to be another
great one uh with them leading it so
yeah so make sure I'm sorry what was
that are they gonna teach like do the
message I think so I think so we'll see
stay tuned stay tuned so yeah youth
Sunday service October 22nd here during
our regular service time secondly since
we've had quite a few visitors and new
people uh join the table lately I wanted
to make sure you're aware about one of
our newest meetups meetups being our
small groups here at the table this one
is an online Meetup it's a really really
good one it's called Open studio so if
you are someone who
enjoys
scrapbooking crafting writing music
making music playing music crocheting
knitting drawing whatever that might be
uh this is a great Meetup for you you
join online twice a month for the quiet
joy of making things doesn't that sound
great it just sounds so like take a
break from your
day get involved in whatever creative
Endeavor that uh lights you up and do
that among community so it's just a nice
way to hold yourself accountable maybe
for doing something you like doing but
maybe don't take the time to do very
often um and to be able to do it with
other people that are are doing similar
things here at the table um so you can
do that from wherever you are since it's
an online group if you would like to
hear more and get details on that group
you can scan the QR code that's up on
the screens and that QR code it has a
couple places for you to check out
meetups just look at our current Meetup
link and that'll give you the
information and just look for Open
studio uh it's led by Gail Bayon and
she's amazing and she would love to have
you join her uh the next time the group
meets um and then also let's let's let's
take some time just to take a breath
Center ourselves you know we come in
here and have things rattling around in
in our brains at least I do um and right
before I got here tonight I heard that
there's war happening in Israel and I'm
going to be completely honest and say I
don't know all the details but I do know
that war anywhere is just a travesty and
involves just lots of hurt pain um and
you name it so I just thought we could
take a moment just as we Center
ourselves in prayer just to remember
those that are being affected either
directly or indirectly by this war that
we would hold them in our hearts and
just pray that they would feel the
presence of God around them and the
protection of God around them during
this time so just join me in a moment of
silence
God we pray for those who are in the
midst of War right now pray that you
would be close to them protecting them
giving them your
comfort your peace your strength and God
in times of uncertainty whether it's war
or something completely different God
help us to find our foundation in you
and to remember that your love is a
center that will hold during troubled
times and you are here for us you're
with us no matter what so God help us to
really receive that in our hearts and
our minds tonight God I pray that the
songs we sing the message that we hear
the people around us God would be
vibrant and deep reminders of Your Love
reminders that we're all
connected that you are with us God and
that we're never
alone God we thank you we thank you for
those
promises be with us tonight and be with
others in the world in Jesus
name amen thanks
Karen um I'm just thankful thankful to
be with you all tonight and I see some
new faces so I just wanted to take a
second to introduce the people that are
up here leading you um hi Bellamy um
this is definitely not a moment for us
to perform for you but a moment for you
guys to join us in worshiping or in
making music or um just filling this
space with creative sound um expression
your heart what you're caring so we want
you guys to feel present in that um if
y'all go ahead and stand with us Gary's
going to get started on the way um but I
just wanted to
let you guys know who we are so this is
Gary Miner he is actually one of our
elders here at the table and Karen was
his wife who was just introducing
everything um this is Josh Tilford on
keys and this is Jenny Lee Swanner soon
to be Torres yay GNA get married this
week you guys her beautiful fiance right
here Mindy um and my name is Mindy as
well and this is Jesse what
so we're really glad to be making music
with you guys and we want you to be
participating with us so please join in
as you feel comfortable Gary go ahead
and get us started
tonight every
battle through every
heartbreak through every
circumstance I believe that you are my
foress oh you are my poor
[Music]
you are my Hiding
Place oh I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you are the
way the
[Music]
truth the
life
I believe through every
blessing through every
promise who every breath I
take I believe that you are
provider oh you are
protector yes you are the one I
love I believe you are the
way
the
truth the
life is I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you
are oh yes you
are
it's a New
Horizon I'm set on
you and you meet me here today with
mercies that I
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come to because they
can't stay long when I'm here with
you it's a New
Horizon I'm set on
you and you may be here today Mercy set
a
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come to because they
can't stay long I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life is I believe you are the
way the truth you are the way the
light I believe you are it's the New
Horizon I'm sit on
you and you me me here today mercies
that I KN oh yeah all my fears and
doubts they it all come to because they
can't stay long I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life is I believe you are the
way the
truth the
light I believe you
are
thank you guys I'm going to go ahead and
dismiss the kids now to go to their
classrooms so to my right we have second
through sixth grade and to my left we
have um four through 1 and toddlers and
babies are back there in the
nursery thank you to our kids ministry
workers who showed up extra early
tonight for a training and who are
loving on our kids every week we really
appreciate your time and energy that you
put into keeping them safe teaching them
the love of
God I'm going to segue us now into the
prayers of the people so if you're with
us for the first time um this is
something we do every week and it's a
space for us to lift up the things that
we're carrying on our hearts up together
before God believing that he's here and
he hears you and he knows what you're
carrying and he wants to carry it with
you and so do we as a community so we're
going to pray through this prayer
together out loud and then we'll leave a
space for you to speak out the name or
situation that you're carrying on your
heart and then we'll close out the
prayer again together out loud would you
guys join me for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
[Music]
James
Angelina for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we've kept in our hearts we pray to
you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
spinning out of control I feeling losing
my
defenses no it's not easy letting go and
trusting you
and if I'm being Hest I know that though
you said you got it no it's not easy let
go and trust in
you so I will stop Brea rest here in
your goodness I know you won't leave
it's my confidence it's my confidence I
will stop Brea the rest here in your
goodness I know you won't leave it's my
confidence it's my
[Music]
confidence spining out of control I
feeling Los
my
defenses no it's not easy letting go and
trusting
you if I'm being Hest I know that though
you say you got it no it's not easy
letting go when trusting you
so I will and Brea rest here in your
goodness I know you won't leave it's my
confidence it's my confidence
will rest here in your goodness I know
you only it's my confidence my
confidence
here in the pal of your ha nothing can
take me away
nothing can take me
away here I am in the palm of your hand
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me
away it's my
[Music]
confidence not hide or dead not a lie
inside my head not a fear or F nothing
can take me away not a hide or a death
not a lie inside my head not a fear or
offense nothing can take me away not lie
death not a lie inside my head not a
fear or renge nothing can take me
away nothing can take me away nothing
can take me away nothing can take me
away
[Music]
way here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me
away here I am in the pal of your hand
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away
[Music]
it's my confidence it's my confidence
it's my confidence my
confidence nothing can take me away
[Music]
nothing in Isaiah chapter
43 it says this is what the Lord says he
who made a way through the sea a path
through the mighty Waters forget the
former things do not dwell on the past
see I'm doing a new thing now it Springs
up do you not perceive it I'm making a
way in the desert and streams in the
Wasteland
[Music]
all this
pain I wonder if I'll ever find my
way I wonder if my life could really
change at
all
all this
Earth could all that is lost ever be
found could a garden come up from this
ground
[Music]
all and you make beautiful things you
make beautiful things out of the
dust you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things out of
[Music]
us
all hope is springing up from this old
ground out of Chaos life is being
found in
you and you make beautiful things you
make beautiful things out of the
[Music]
Dust you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things out of us
and you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things out of the
dark and you make beautiful things you
make beautiful things out
[Music]
of
you make me new you are me
making
me you make me new you are
making me
new you
Beau beautiful
[Music]
things make beautiful things out
of oh you make beautiful things you make
beautiful things out of the
Dust oh you make beautiful things you
make beautiful things out
[Music]
of you
make
you out
of you make me new you are
making me
new you make me new you are
new You Make Me New
you are
making me
new God would you show us where you're
at work even where we don't see
it where we can't perceive it
God would we trust you with our broken
pieces
with our
shame with our sin with our
fear would we trust that even there you
can come and do a new
thing in the midst of our pain in the
midst of war in the midst of casualties
God would we trust that you and your
love are big enough to come and do a new
work
to redeem and to restore and to make
Beauty out of
Ashes to continue the
story you're not finished
[Music]
God and we want to believe that
tonight we want to believe that there's
[Music]
more so do your work in our hearts
God meet us in our pain in our mess and
do your
work
amen thank you guys y'all um turn to the
people around you make them feel welcome
and at home and then Brett will get us
started on our
message
and peace it is so good to be with you
all my name is Brett and um it's a joy
to welcome you a joy to welcome those
joining us online love you all lots and
um anyone here who is new tonight thank
you um just thank you for joining us in
this in this space I hope you feel um
just a sense of love and welcome and you
know all of that I hope you I hope you
feel that um since that's who um Jesus
was and is um just the most hospitable
of all people and uh and so we we see
seek to mirror that same uh welcome so
um we are in let's see this is week two
in our series titled the Bible doesn't
say that and uh I love the this face
this gentleman's making so good um that
actually the face captures it because
there's a lot of these little
sayings kind of floating around in the
culture um sometimes often in church
culture as well that uh our kind of well
Loosely based on the Bible
um but often like are not like everyone
assumes they're a direct quote from
scripture when you know they're not and
uh it's like last week we looked at um
the the statement God has a wonderful
plan for your life and kind of the ways
we interpret that and kind of play it
out in like very specific ways into you
know this whole kind of idea of like oh
I've got to follow the plan it's like a
blueprint for my life and what if I
missed it what if I what if I make the
wrong ter or you know it kind of can
lead weirdly to like all this anxiety
around trying to follow the plan um and
so our this week though um the the
little statement in the title of the
message is it's a famous One everything
happens for a
reason have you ever heard this yeah
yeah I I assume so based on the
collective oh uh when I put through it
out there um yeah this is definitely
this is a classic and if it had kind of
a a proof text or something from the
scripture um I think it would probably
be Romans 8 verse 28 where the Apostle
Paul writes and he says and we know that
in all things God works for the good of
those who love him who have been called
according to his purpose and um we'll
return to this passage later to to kind
of um read it with fresh eyes and uh so
this this statement everything happens
for reason actually as I Was preparing
for this whole series I realized there's
like like in ways this is a close cousin
of last week God has a wonderful plan
for your life everything happens for
reason um there's like I noticed there's
a number of these that are are kind of
all circling around the notion of like
God's will in uses kind of a theological
words God's sovereignty and such um
because I think this is something we
really wrestle with is you know how do I
Square God you know willing all of these
things and then uh with the struggles
and the pain right cuz like just like we
talked about last week these things
these statements work easily enough when
everything's going great you know like
when I just feel like God has a plan and
I am walking it out and it's going
swimmingly you know well then in that I
mean there's no real theological
wrestling or oh no you know um we feel
great about it the Trouble Comes of
course when um things get sideways and
and most Troublesome i' say about this
phrase is uh that that often um well let
me back up I'll say it this I think this
actually can be good let me name the
good of this before I go into some
critiques um the good of it I would say
is it it works not just even when things
are going well this is quite nice um
when you're hitting like the bumps in
the road of life you know like this I
would say actually this could be uh like
a real win like for example uh maybe
you're like up for promotion
and at work and you don't get the
promotion and there can be a certain
comfort in like okay you know what I'm
just going to trust like everything
happens for a reason you know or you
apply to a number of colleges you don't
get into your first choice you get into
your second or your third and you say
okay you know what I can live with this
everything what happens for a reason
right and that's like there's a certain
chill and I think there's actually um
not just chill I would say it's like a
certain wisdom and maturity you know to
like even trust like not to shake your
fist at the heavens over every last
disappointment and that didn't go my way
and you know like there can be I think a
certain perspective here of okay you
know what like uh like when I'm I think
folks who are younger tend to would say
like you know we have a certain idea of
how our life should go and we get like
very locked into it and when you know
the plan isn't happening we're like very
stressed out and I think this is where
this statement can be good like hey just
know like sometimes I mean how many
times have you had this experience where
like the thing you thought you wanted
doesn't happen but the thing you get you
realize okay actually that worked out
really genius you know I don't know you
like you end up meeting your partner
someone you know at at this school that
you didn't want to go to initially but
it turns out all for the good you know
etc etc right you can see where okay
everything happens for a reason it can
be some perspective some needed
perspective in a world where we can get
kind of locked in on like my plan and
how I want it to go okay um however just
like we talked about last week the
trouble comes when well when the trouble
comes when when it's not a the bumps in
the road of Life uh when it is like
major suffering and catastrophe and
heartbreak uh like like when the the
marriage ends in
divorce and it's not amicable and it's
it's messy and you think oh my gosh did
I just waste like 20 years of my life
with someone who didn't even love me
like is that is that what this this was
when the cancer diagnosis comes and you
watch as someone you love has to suffer
through chemo and radiation and and
round after round of these and then and
maybe even surgery and I mean suddenly
like can you see where hey everything
happens for a reason
like sudden it just it becomes like at
best just
thin you know just a thin response like
um at worst it's obscene it it just
sounds like a it's like a it's a curse
word or something it's just like what
are you saying what are be quiet just
reminds me of if you've ever read the
book of Job marvelous book um really
reads kind of like a play of a man going
through major suffering and his um co-s
suffering or not co-s sufferers but his
friends come to comfort him and they
spend the first um I think it's seven
days in Silence with him which is a
beautiful expression of like empathy and
you know um but the trouble all comes
when they do
what when they start talking when they
and then you get some of this theology
you know hey job everything happens for
a reason I mean meanwhile all his
children just passed away he's
incredibly sick I mean his livelihood is
gone I mean his his life is falling
apart you everything happens F reason
old job you know it just it doesn't work
like at all but uh the trick is I mean
it's one thing to say well this just
doesn't work you know but there's
there's some theology behind this though
there's there's things we have to kind
of unpack and wrestle with because I
mean well the logic would go well but if
God is
God if God is all powerful if God Is You
know writing the script of everything
that happens in
history well then is God writing
in tragedy and horror and wickedness
like I mean it's evil pain malevolence
like it's it's one thing you know
there's a certain view of sin which I
think is good that be kind of
therapeutic like um a sense of like sin
a sickness and that again kind of works
for certain things in a helpful way um
but at other levels
um not so helpful where I mean just face
it like human beings and what we're
capable of like oh my gosh you know some
of you have bumped up against like true
evil and malevolence in your life where
people are like
doing evil and they and they they liked
it you know and that like that's
startling I mean that's the stuff that
sends you to therapy for years like
working through like why didn't know the
world could be like this you know it's
it's a wakeup call um like suddenly can
you see where the question becomes like
did God um intend that did God I mean
hey if everything happens for a reason
was that like that was part of the plan
to like well that you had to go through
I mean even sometimes people say like
well you know it's so good that you went
through that because now you can help
others which by the way I do think is
true like in the sense of you can help
others after you've been there's a
certain Authority that comes when you've
suffered and then you can speak to that
right so I'm not trying to downplay that
but it gets theologically very
problematic when it's like so God's just
doing this over and over again to people
so that everyone can empathize with each
other you know like oh well gosh they
went through it so now you have to go
through it so you can help them well now
you have to go through it so you can
help you know I mean it's just becomes
the sort of conundrum of like what is
God the author of evil and pain and
suffering um just to be clear as I go
into this I'm certainly I'm giving you a
um a Christian theology but it is an
interpretation there are Christians who
would defend this notion and would say
yes yes God God Wills these things I
think of like one I won't see the name
um but a a prominent Pastor um who there
was a tornado that like swept through
somewhere in the Midwest and I mean
killed like dozens of people and and
this Pastor said well that was the that
was the Finger of God you know being
dragged across
like um and whether whether he meant
that metaphorically or literally I think
is sort of neither here nor there what
he's implying is it's right it's God
that bring that brought that catastrophe
right this becomes very problematic when
it's not just things human beings are
doing right but even sort of uh nature
gone crazy like tornadoes and tsunamis
and is that you know God opening up the
doors of the sea to sweep away I mean
think of like the terrible tsunamis that
have happened I we're talking tens of
thousands even a 100 thousand people
like can you see where this is
incredibly um I think in a problematic
kind of way to think this through but to
the point what are we to do I mean if
God is
God isn't isn't God the author of all
these things um how do we if God is love
love and created all things in love then
why is there evil why is there tragedy
right that would be maybe the way to
frame it um to to help kind of respond
to this I want to draw from a a
Christian Theologian from many moons ago
he's writing in the about 400s uh so
fifth century his name was St Augustine
and uh there's many ideas from Augustine
I don't love um but he was a genius I
mean theological genius no doubt and had
um many of his ideas others are really
good and I think this is a topic where
he's excellent but I don't want to give
you like long quotes of Theology and
such if you want to dig in more any you
theology nerds out there you just email
me and I don't know well you can read
Inc and some other things from uh from
Augustin but uh let me kind of I'll do
my best just to kind of sum it up where
he I think how he might respond to this
and I'll draw on some metaphors and such
that have been really prominent in
Christian um history so I think here's
what I think St August might say
something like this where the light no
longer
shines we call it
Darkness where health no longer rains we
call it sickness where the eye no longer
sees we call it
blindness and where the good has been
lost we call that evil in other words
what Augustin is naming is that um evil
suffering death these are not things
that are um created by God evil is not
created by God like well you know for
the world of work there's got to be
equal parts good and evil so I shall
create the good and then the evil and
there shall be an antagonism and a and a
fight all through history but this is
how people will grow and mature like
that is um that's not good Christian
theology that's like a super uh yeah
almost like a a strong dualism rather
than a temporary dualism sorry I know
that's some of yall aren't into theology
stuff but um for those who were tracking
like it's you know it's it's too um it's
almost like in the heart of God there's
these there's good and evil and they're
forever fighting and that's the story of
History I don't think that's no I mean
go all the way back to Genesis right God
creates in love God creates goodness I
mean that's what he uh God says every
step right good good good very good very
good right so it's Creation in um in
love and so the way to think I think the
the metaphor of darkness is a really
good one because we think of like well
darkness is real it exists and it's like
yes and no like it is a we have an
experience of Darkness clearly these
lights go out in here and I don't know I
don't think that light's going to be
very strong coming through that stain
glass you know so it would get real dark
right so you would say look darkness is
real God has created Darkness but of
course we realize like well actually
Darkness isn't like a thing it is the
name we give to the absence of the
light uh so in other words where
goodness and love and compassion wither
and fade away where God's good
order
um and control of nature kind of Wither
then suddenly you get circumstances that
we call all evil um this is known in
kind of Christian theology as like the
fall right that that
something has gone wrong in the
cosmos uh and this I mean no matter what
you think of Christianity and and
various ideas I don't in a you know
group this big there's I don't assume
everyone's like a Christian you know um
you know there's I think at least that
one Doctrine most people would agree on
the doctrine of the Fall you know like
yep something's gone terribly wrong in
the world that we agree you know whether
you trust that Christ is you know
helping to heal and restore all well
that's sort of something else but at the
very least I think we'd all agree like
yeah it's a mess um I think another
metaphor Augustine uses is the the
language of um evil is is a is parasitic
it's a parasite on the good has no life
of its
own uh it was this summer we went on a
uh family reunion out to Broken Bow
Oklahoma we are living a good life out
there we got a cabin and so there's like
it's my wife's side of the family so big
family so everyone's there and of course
there's like all the kids you know um so
many kids and they're all playing out in
the woods because that's you know you
got the cabin you got the and so they're
all playing and then like days on end
and then one day one of them comes home
and they got a tick just right there you
know know just that big fat just sucking
the life blood out of them I mean it was
horrible oh min's losing it it's bad um
and so of course we have to gather all
the children you know and we line them
like all 40 of them just an assembly
line of children and were're just coming
through every inch of the hair you know
like there's something like I can handle
spiders and crickets and grasshoppers
even uh June bugs I'm fine with June
bugs some of y'all can't handle June
bugs gu that prickliness of their legs
I'm fine with them but something about
parasites I'm just like oh my gosh I
can't handle this you know um in fact
this is how I got my kids to um stop
chewing their toenails that's
right not their
fingernails so gross like what are you
doing but we told him that you'll get
worms that's how you get
worms and they're like dear lord they're
like we repent you know um that's that
put a put an end to it um so I can
handle you know like but something about
parasites like that and I think that's
such a powerful metaphor for what evil
is it's like everything good and
beautiful and true that God has
created and then you have like almost
like the
nothingness from which God created comes
and like latches on in leeches it's like
a it's like a wasting disease that just
tearing at everything that God
intends
so kind of coming back to our theme you
know does everything happen for a reason
does everything that happens happen for
a god ordained
reason
no because evil
sin death are not
reasonable do not operate According to
some Divine
logic cancer does not happen for a
reason like oh if only you were really
spiritual you could see that actually
you know um tsunamis do not happen for a
reason
dementia does not happen for some
higher
purpose it's there there parasites on
the good it's the it's it's wherever the
good and the Beautiful and the true has
started to fade and wither that's where
evil what we call evil
manifests and um it seems to me though
that many
Christians have forgotten
this or or perhaps never understood it
and so when tragedy comes what often
flows from our mouths is we're trying to
make sense of I think people are very
well-intentioned um trying to comfort
you know but inevitably it's it's
statements like this everything happens
for a reason that ends up making God
sound like the author of evil
itself um to help kind of unpack this I
want to um invite up my good friend and
sister-in-law Mindy rynolds y'all give
her a hand she comes
up thank
you you go here we'll leave it down
here um so I think I I wanted Mindy to
share some of her story on on one of
these topics because um I think I don't
know there's something about when you
see folks who are up here week after
week there can be a a weird um I don't
know thing that happens in people's
minds where it's sort of
like everything always goes splendidly
in their life you know it's just my life
I'm the problem or something you know
something along those lines um and so I
wanted to I don't know give you like a I
just wanted to give you some insight
into Mindy in her own Journey so Minnie
could you share with everyone like some
of the story of your own you had a whole
season of pretty intense um really
intense suffering um so could you share
a little bit about about that so kind of
bring everyone in the
loop yeah um I took a lot of notes
because I'll go way too far so um bear
with me if I'm looking down so um in
2013 my husband and I Josh uh we had two
little girls he was in an NBA program um
at UTD and we were kind of on the fence
about like whether we were going to
continue to grow our family or not so
for the meantime we just decided to hold
off wait on it um but then against
despite our best efforts we ended up
unexpectedly pregnant and with twins um
it was twin boys they were identical uh
so obviously we were shocked at first
and you know
like there was definitely the the shock
factor I laughed a lot like this cannot
be happening but um I am a twin for
those of you who don't know so it was
kind of like this cool thing uh you know
it seemed like okay here we are we're
moving forward we're excited family of
four here we come or four kids so um so
yeah we we all got really excited we
started imagining a new story uh
obviously doing all the things that you
do when you're pregnant you're dreaming
of that future of those kids what
they're going to be like you know their
friendships you're making a whole world
world you know and and we became a
family like we're naming them with our
girls you know what I mean all the
things um so anyway if you don't know
twins are considered now in these days
not when I was in utero but it's
considered highrisk now so immediately
you start meeting with um Specialists uh
it's not a normal pregnancy anymore it
is now you know like you're kind of
waiting at every turn for there to be
possible danger so we started going to a
specialist that you know reg routine
appointments I do lots of sonograms
which is kind of fun at first you're
getting to see them all the time so
you're bonding in that really cool way
showing pictures everybody um and they
let you know you know just so that
you're prepared there's this thing
called
TTS um and it's a syndrome that can
happen with moms who are pregnant with
twins where there's uneven distribution
of fluids and nutrients and we're going
to be tracking that watching for it you
know blah blah blah everything's great
great you're normal the babies are
normal you know it's just something that
we're going to be watching for so you
know of course you're like scared that
that's going to happen but everything's
good you know so we keep continuing on
with our pregnancy um we had a trip to
Europe plan for Josh's NBA program we go
to Europe I get back go in for my normal
appointment and then it was like
everything turned from there um so we
had the appointment surprise you have
teach
TTS um we call the other Specialists um
there are only two in the world at that
time one of them happened to be in Texas
in Austin I I believe and um and we
start talking about surgery and uh they
wanted a wait they're like you know what
everything looks good right now so let's
not do surgery we don't want to tamper
with things before they that you know
it's absolutely necessary because that's
a whole another introduction of issues
so let's just wait you're doing good so
then you know the clock starts ticking
we waiting for that next appointment
blah blah blah the next appointment um
we watched Jesse's heart stop on the
monitor in front of us and so obviously
this was really difficult um but they
told us um when we lost Jesse the next
two weeks are going to be the most
critical for Jonah our other son and
we'll see how he does because that
transition is you know extremely
stressful for the other baby in uterus
blah blah blah we're like What happens
to the one that died you'll just keep
carrying him and as a twin I was just
like a wreck you know like trying to
process death and life in my womb at the
same time um all the dreams that we had
you know starting to
die um anyways we are surrounded by lots
of support lots of love lots of family
but um we're just waiting to get through
those two weeks weeks praying you know
all the things um we get through them
everything seems good the other shoe
didn't drop you know so we're like all
right we keep going seems like a normal
pregnancy from there on we start we stop
meeting with the Specialists because
they're like you made it through the
worst of it this is just now a normal
pregnancy so we go back to our normal
Midwife we're meeting with her
everything seems great she actually
leaves town and one night I go into a
Titanic contraction and Jonah stops
moving uh we call the doctor on call at
that point he has us come in to just
check and see what's going on and his
heart stops and so we lose our other
baby I delivered him that both of them
that next day um so it was just I mean
it wrecked me
um and I haven't even looked at my notes
y'all I'm
sorry
um yeah so if you've if you've ever had
a child in the hospital you know what
it's like you you know they wrap the
baby up they put you in a wheelchair you
go down to your car you're holding the
baby in your arms to leave a hospital
empty-handed with a box of bonnets that
have been crocheted and there's no child
wearing them it's like a whole another
kind of walk of shame it was just
excruciating your milk comes in there's
no one to feed it's just it was a loss
that I just was not prepared for I don't
think you could be you know what I mean
but um you're getting pamphlets of like
still birth and what to do about still
birth and how to recover and meanwhile
lots of people that love you and care
about you and mean the best are trying
to find answers and a lot of times the
answer was well minty everything happens
for a
reason
and that was just anyway it was
extremely painful to try to make sense
of that you know and to receive that in
love yeah what um what were was that the
main statement you heard or were there
others too that people there were lots
of
statements one was I think God aborted
the first baby so that the second baby
could
live um I mean there were so many things
that were said that I just sat there and
mo usually I just I just sat there and
tears would fill my eyes and I just
wouldn't have a
response one my grandmother love her to
death she's gone now but she was very
sassy and she asked Maggie one time like
so is Mindy done with all her boohoo now
like
um oh yeah you know God needed two more
angels in heaven all the ones that I'm
sure you've heard or you know maybe
we've said in our wor wor moments just
because you're uncomfortable with
watching someone you love in pain and
you want to try to fix it you know yeah
what um I'm curious as to for you
personally so you're going through this
obviously folks are giving you you know
they're processing their own way and
they're saying at times really UNH
helpful things how how did you process
this with God and how did you start to
come to a place of I don't know what you
would call it peace or you know
theologic whether it was more I don't
know if it was more intellectual or more
um just emotional at the feeling level
but how did what was that Journey like
um well it wasn't overnight I can start
by saying that it was long and it
definitely did change the way I
interacted with my faith with the things
I had been taught growing up um just
with my framework of of God and how he
interacts with us and how he loves us I
mean it it definitely shifted a lot of
things um but I would say part of what
helped shift it was lived
experience there when you're so close to
the pain when it first
happens I mean it's all the things that
we learn about grief you know you go
through anger you go through except I
mean it's a long journey and there's
lots of emotions and you know there was
lots of anger there was um confusion not
being able to make sense of it there was
one moment that stands out so clearly in
my head um where we had just lost uh
Jesse and my mom came over
and in all with with total love in her
heart um she said Mindy me and all of my
friends are praying for Jonah and I just
looked at her and I was like that didn't
do anything for Jesse like why you I
mean there's just that emotion when
you're going through it of like
I don't think I care anymore you know
like great keep praying it's doing a
whole heck of a lot you know there's
that process that you go through of just
wanting to be angry um and sometimes the
only one you can direct your anger at is
this God that you've been told is
orchestrating everything is planning
your life is giving you the blueprint
you know and now you're supposed to make
sense of why he took two children away
and kept dangling carrots in front of
you all all along the you know the
journey um so part of it was just
perspective and time and remembering
that I don't have the whole picture and
this world isn't just about me and my
suffering and you know the longer you
get from it um there is there is a part
of that phrase Time Heals all wounds
there is part of that that is true I
don't know if it's healing I feel like
it scars all wounds you know like it
makes it easier to move forward um and
so I I think part of it was time also
Brett recommended a book to me um called
force of will by a guy named Mike
stueland I think is his name and if any
of you have um grief or loss that you're
dealing with I highly recommend that
book and that's coming from someone
who's not a huge reader um but that was
really the turning point for me I feel
like in trying to rebuild a framework
and this guy um he just had so much
truth and honesty about his own
suffering and his own loss and he wrote
A Psalm in the book and um the psalm the
first line of it just was it felt so
true and and it said God what good are
you
really and I just felt seen I felt like
that's what I want to say to you you
know like what is all of this about if
you're not going to answer our prayers
if you're not going to write the wrongs
what good are you you know that's what
it felt like and it gave me a place to
be honest with god um and then it goes
on in the book um he since my superhero
God that I had kind of grown up to
believe in this Santa Claus you know who
does fix all of our problems
that that had failed me and that was no
longer working that wasn't an option for
me to believe in anymore and um Mike in
this book takes you back through the Old
Testament God who walks with the
Israelites through the desert and the
Old Testament God who um let David cry
out to him in honesty and in pain and
rail against him and job who's suffering
and and is able to say something about
it to God and and God God acknowledges
his pain he doesn't cover over it he
acknowledges it you know and then fast
forward to Jesus his own son who's like
God why did you betray me you know why
did you abandon me and and it gave me a
new framework for a God who is with us
you know
Emmanuel um someone who isn't just up in
the sky and far away but a God who sits
with us in our pain and sees us and
knows us and isn't just there to just
wave his magic wand and fix everything
and make it right and rescue us that's
that's not all there is to God you know
and sometimes he does answer the prayers
and I can't make sense of why some
prayers are answered and why some aren't
but what I do know is that whether it's
answered or not he's there with me he's
he's feeling it he's caring it with me
um so that was very very helpful in
moving forward yeah I think um thank you
for sharing and I think one of the
reasons I was excited for Minnie to
share with you all is um I think this
comes out a lot as she leads in worship
if you'll tune into to her prayers and
things they're often coming from this
this place and um when she's praying it
I know it's always so powerful for me
because I know what's behind those words
you know those aren't cheap words these
are hard truths that you've um wrestled
with and wrestled with God I think of
Jacob who wrestled with God you know and
that's it's sort of like that's what I
hear you naming is a wrestling to um
come through the experience and um not
leaving it behind but to heal SL Scar
from it and but still be able to move
forward um and it's incredibly
incredibly powerful um yeah so thank you
thank you for sharing and just opening
up so honestly and vulnerably you all
give her a
[Applause]
hand thank you
br um so in closing I wanted to come
back to um Romans
8 and it says when we know um that in
all things God works for the good of
those who love him who have been called
according to his
purpose and I I think this is actually
like instead of hearing this and hearing
it say everything that happens is good
or if only you're a really True Believer
everything that happens in your life
will be good uh which is I think not
quite what it's saying instead it's it's
this image of
um some things happen and they're good
and beautiful and true and in alignment
with the will of God and other things
happen and they're part of a fall Fallen
broken Cosmos but God will work with the
world with his creation as it is and
will as we Sayang earlier make beautiful
things out of that dust in muuk in
Meer and some of you right now are in a
season where you feel like you are in
the dust the muck the mud the Meer and
following Mindy um God's word to you um
is that Christ is with you in it I mean
I think of the Christian story like what
is the crucifixion
about it's God going all the way down
into the depths of the worst kinds of
suffering I mean that's a picture not of
a God who is distant and like wow I hope
youall figure that out like no this is
the God who enters into it with us and
then brings about what Resurrection
Life and I I think if I if I had to kind
of sum it up um I would say that
Resurrection is God's answer or response
to the problem of evil and
suffering and there's seasons in life
where it may feel like that's not enough
I needed Resurrection Life like now I
needed healing now you know so I don't
mean this as a sort of easy answer um
but I mean it in a kind of costly um
like what is God
doing well if if scripture is to be
trusted and if Jesus is to be
trusted God is working in weaving and
calling and drawing all things towards
their final end and tell us in The God
Who is love and um as Christians that's
that's our hope that's our that's our
hope in the midst of uh a really often a
really hurting hurting World in a lot of
pain so
um yeah I hope that resonates in some
way and um I see tears and eyes so I
trust that God's speaking speaking to
some people tonight in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight um as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
and the wine I think it's such a a power
moment where we I mean just think of
what we do we take in the broken
shattered body of
Jesus but it's both like broken and
still made whole it's it's we take it in
but it's not just hopelessness like just
a connection with the despair of the
world or something but it's it's the
crucified and resurrected one it's the
broken body and that same body made
whole
and and we take it together we become
part of that body of Christ so as you
come forward I I hope that's the the um
heart posture in which we participate in
this tonight uh so the way we'll go
about this is uh we'll start with the
front rows and we'll just work our way
back um everyone is welcome to
participate we practice an Open Table um
so no matter your theology or
denomination or whatever if you want to
participate then then you we would love
for you to do that having said that
there's no Stigma if you don't want to
participate that's okay um just know the
red is wine the white is grape juice and
uh finally you can just partake whenever
you'd like so this is the table not at
the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
[Music]
table
J
[Music]
for
is
whenever you're ready I want to invite
you guys to stand with us we're g to
close out the service with a song called
Raise A Hallelujah which you're probably
very familiar with if you've come for
any length of time to the table but
tonight instead of its normal style um I
want us to offer it up kind of like
Leonard Cohen song it's a cold and it's
a Broken Hallelujah um because sometimes
that's all we have to offer um and I
believe that God meets us there
[Music]
so
I raise a
hallelu in the presence of my
[Music]
enemies I raise a
hallelu
louder than the
[Music]
unbel I raise a
hallelu my weapon is a
[Music]
Melody I raise a
hallelu
Heaven comes to fight for
me I'm going to
sing in the middle of the
storm louder and loud you're going to
hear my Praises
Roar up from
thees Hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive I raise a
[Music]
hallelu with everything inside of
me I raise a
hallelu
I will watch The
Darkness I raise a
Hallelujah in the midle of the
mystery I raise a
hallelu fear you lost your hold on
me and I'm going to
sing in the middle of the
storm louder and
loud you're going to hear my Praises
Ro From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeat the king is
alive I'm going to
sing in the middle of the
storm louder and
louder you're going to hear my Praises
Roar up from
thees Hope will
arise death is defeat
the king is
[Music]
alive try to hold it
together thank
you thank you too Josh was
beautiful I love being part of this
church for that
reason where people can be
real We can question and
doubt and have it met with such
compassion and
empathy and what I believe is just a
true view of God God that is with us in
our crap in our
struggle thank you so much for being
here tonight your presence in en riched
everything that happened
here if you're visiting with us you
really picked a good night to be here
please don't leave without uh filling
out a visitor card on your way out uh
put it in the Box out on the little tiny
table out there we just want to have a
chance to say thank you and say like we
see you and we're glad you're here you
can also do that um visitor card online
using the QR code up there um if if you
need prayer a hug someone to talk to
feel free to find me after the service
or just grab somebody around you this is
such a place of love and friendship and
compassion I'm not the only one who can
give you a hug or a prayer um this is
such a loving loving Community we want
to be there for you
um and I really more than ever want to
send you out with a blessing as you go
these are words that are for this
Community they're for you whether you're
here or watching online so you can hold
your arms out in a posture to
receive or just open your
heart you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
and Lowe's and everything in
between go with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these gifts of
love and
compassion and empathy to everyone you
come in contact with this week you are
loved be blessed blessed we hope to see
you back here next Sunday good
[Music]
night
hallelu I
hallelu I raise
Hallelujah I
Hallelujah I raise the
hallelu I raise the
Hallelujah and I'm going to
sing in the middle of the
stor louder and
louder you're going to hear my Praises
Ro Up From the
Ashes hope will
death is
defeated the king is
[Music]
alive